this is senegal home to 15 million
people
one of the region's relatively more
stable democracies
and the westernmost country in africa
this is dakar its capital and senegal's
westernmost city and
within dakar this is the african
renaissance monument
situated on the very western edge of the
cape
verde peninsula on the 3rd of april
2010 this was the place to be
in africa it was the day before the 50th
anniversary of the country's
independence
and 19 presidents plus u.s congressman
jesse jackson
had flown in to witness the unveiling of
this humongous bronze
statue at 49 meters
or 160 feet high it was
and still is the tallest statue on the
continent
taller even than the statue of liberty
or christ the redeemer
the socialist realist style man woman
and child
were intended to represent quote africa
emerging from darkness
from five centuries of slavery and two
centuries of colonialism
the hill on which it stands however is
awkwardly surrounded by squatter camps
and garbage dumps
which may help explain why today over a
decade later
it never quite achieved its stated goal
of rivaling the eiffel tower
as a tourist destination there are many
strange things about this statue
for one there's its liberal use of
nudity to represent a 96
muslim country there's it's officially
25
but rumored 70 million dollar price tag
in a country where half the population
lives below the poverty line
indeed thousands of locals protested the
project
calling it an embarrassing testament to
the government's corruption
self-obsession and backward priorities
then there was the president's
controversial decision to personally
claim
35 of the profits to this public
monument
but far stranger than all of this is the
fact that
despite a 50 local unemployment rate
this entire piece was outsourced to a
foreign firm
and not just any foreign firm
this massive tribute to african
ingenuity and pride
was built by north korea
the african renaissance monument isn't
unique in this respect
all over africa even in europe and
elsewhere
are statues museums buildings and
monuments
built entirely by and in north korea
this is in fact its single largest
export sponsored by curiosity stream and
nebula where you can watch the extended
version
of this video when the so-called
democratic people's republic of korea
was founded in 1948
its existence was recognized only by a
handful of communist countries like the
soviet union
china and romania decades before it
began unification talks with the south
north korea was looking for
international legitimacy
a need for which it was very willing to
overlook
just about anything kim il-sung was also
committed to the ideological spread of
socialism
actively trying to promote the juche
philosophy of self-reliance
long before it would be laughed at as a
model for the rest of the world
it was for this reason that this nascent
nation began making allies in africa
it did so by donating money weapons and
soldiers
all of which went a long way at a time
of desperate need
the dprk military for instance trained
somali forces
in their fight against ethiopia who had
previously supported the south during
the korean war
a few years later when ethiopia's
government was overthrown by marxists
north korea began supporting ethiopia's
fight against somalia
both of which established with it
diplomatic relations
in the 70s north korea sent thousands of
troops to angola
during its civil war at the same time
at home the kim il-sung regime was busy
sowing the seeds of what would become a
propaganda machine
rivaling any of history's most intense
cults of personality
this began rather inconspicuously with
the founding in 1958
of the mansurday art studio backed by
the supreme leader himself
its task was simple though not easy
forged the public image of a leader who
was then dangerously at risk of being
seen
as merely human in practical terms
this meant painting murals architecting
buildings and sculpting monuments
thanks to its artistic monopoly
virtually all of pyongyang's landmarks
are its work this includes the
flame-topped juche
tower which stands exactly one meter
taller than the washington monument
all of its propaganda posters and the
giant murals
inside the pyongyang underground in the
70s and 80s
mansudai was also assigned the job of
constructing diplomatic gifts to current
or potential allies
ethiopia for example was given its
victory monument
likewise the presidential palace of
madagascar was built by north korea
completely free of charge it was a cheap
easy way to win
friends and influence autocrats then
as with all things north korean a
tectonic shift
occurred in the 90s while the country
was never
completely the obedient puppet state
moscow wanted it to be
it did very much rely on the soviet
union for material support
with its collapse north korea instantly
lost its biggest
ally and financial backer it needed cash
it needed a lot and it needed it
yesterday
the problem was frankly it didn't have
all that much to offer
by 1990 south korea's gnp
had grown to 237 billion dollars
to the north's puny 23.
faced with this existential predicament
it turned to several
unconventional gigs in the intervening
three plus decades
the mansude art studio had both honed
its craft and grown to become
one of if not the largest art studios in
the world
occupying about 30 acres in pyongyang
its campus contains 13 creative groups
7 factories and 50 supply departments
there's a paper mill soccer stadium
kindergarten
sauna clinic and gift shop it has a
reputation as the most prestigious
career path for promising north korean
students
each of its four thousand artists is
expected to churn out a steady stream of
propaganda
two paintings a month for example
according to a south korean study
kim family artifacts including all films
books
murals statues and so on add up to 40
percent
of the state's visible budget so while
the mansuri
oversees projects division was
originally commissioned for the sole
purpose of making allies
after the fall of the soviet union it
took on a far
more sinister purpose generating foreign
currency for the personal bank accounts
of the kim family
the african renaissance monument
although the tallest
is only one of dozens of projects
altogether
they've earned an estimated 160 million
dollars for the regime
in the last 10 years one of its more
loyal customers is the nation of namibia
it commissioned a 5000 seat war memorial
presidential palace independence museum
military museum
ministry of defense headquarters
munitions factory and presidential
statue
property records indicate north korea
bought a warehouse for around 120
000 us dollars in 2004 and some locals
say they still see north koreans come
and go
to this day its northern neighbor angola
is also a frequent patron in addition to
a park and peace monument
there's a curiously shaped mausoleum of
its first
president which locals gave the nickname
sputnik
in the congo a statue of its third
president
rose eyebrows for its suspicious
likeness to the body of kim jong-il
some speculate it was a lazy repurposing
though the artists can be forgiven
given the lack of diversity involved in
their day-to-day work
in zimbabwe several of its statues
generated extra controversy
thanks to its especially egregious past
in the 80s north korean trained troops
massacred thousands of citizens
after the rhodesian bush war there are
even a few examples outside
africa visitors to cambodia's angkor
wat for example may also stop by the
nearby panorama museum
which was designed built and is now
operated by north korea
inside is a 120 meter long 13 meter high
360 degree
mural featuring 45 000 people it was
painted by
63 artists over four months after
spending
over a year drawing the outline in
exchange
north korea is entitled to 100 of the
proceeds for the first 10 years
followed by a 10-year 50-50 split with a
cambodian government
upon hearing all this one might
reasonably ask
what's in it for them mansude is
sanctioned by the united nations
doing business with it is also likely to
anger locals
why not purchase from a more reputable
professional
one answer is best explained strangely
by
a non-descript fountain in frankfurt
this relatively small 264 thousand
dollar
mansuri built sculpture is the only one
built for a western democracy when asked
why north korea was awarded the contract
the commissioning museum director
said it was simply a question of style
if you're looking to buy socialist
realist art
no one in the world is better qualified
to make it
north korean artists have decades of
experience
and all of it frozen in time
the second reason is just that it's very
very cheap as captive citizens its
laborers are forced to accept criminally
low
wages in other words there's plenty of
demand around the world for propaganda
and the kim regime has both plenty of
supply
and experience as the cost of sanctions
violations
increase some countries will find the
risks too
high others however will surely only do
so
more covertly dragging the most
secretive country in the world
even further into the shadows
such is the dilemma of sanctions impose
too many and defenders will only retreat
further from the international order
how do you as a country punish without
permanently
excluding you can watch the full version
of this video
which replaces this ad with my thoughts
on north korea's sanctions
on nebula the streaming site i helped
create
to give you the very best viewing
experience
there are no ads videos are available
early
and you can watch entirely exclusive
original content
we've partnered with curiositystream
home to great documentaries on
technology history and science
like this one about america's role as
the world's police
so that you can get it and nebula for
less than 15
a year sign up with the link in the
description
and watch the extended version of this
video over
on nebula